no offense doctor but did you ever ask
yourself why the dinosaur became extinct
he couldn't adapt his environment
changed and he couldn't change with it
general practice was great in its day
but this is now you're wrong maybe I am
maybe I'm just trying to justify wanting
the good life talk about memories that
is James Brolin and his Emmy
award-winning role as a doctor on Marcus
Welby MD I love that show the Hollywood
legend has been gracing our screens for
nearly six decades now appearing in more
than 100 projects thank you very much
now you can find him as a patriarch of
the short family on the hit CBS show
it's called life in pieces in tonight's
season four premiere we find him relying
on his daughter after his wife suffers
an injury listen you know what dad it's
not a problem I won't say anything to
mom okay just let me know when you need
me Oh Heather your mom wanted a
strawberry smoothie I'll take one too
sure dad but I want mine chocolate and
more like milkshake okay oh but we're
out of ice cream I know the market has
it so since you're there I'll make you a
list oh you also need to get some pin
joins us at the table to discuss life in
pieces that show keeps going you came on
when it first came on the air and you
said we'll see how it's go out it goes
it was kicked to the curb a couple of
times but CBS said come on back yeah
here you are season no yeah and matter
of fact it's kind of a premiere tonight
because we were pulled off the air while
two shows replaced us and now we're back
we have two shows starting tonight and
we're on for 13 weeks and I'm hoping we
gain an audience to come back though
James nothing against the other shows
but isn't kind of great to get the call
to say we want you to come back but yeah
it was like somebody made a mistake your
character always looks like he's trying
to figure life out talk about life in
pieces well when I read this pilot I I
really saw my dad in it how so
oh he was he was a star
magna [ __ ] lot out of Caltech right and
Donald Douglas pulled him out too to
figure out why the dc-3 was falling
apart vibrationally right so smart guy
had five different different careers in
his lifetime and everyday at 5 o'clock
he'd come home and take a little nip and
he was silly after that so as four kids
developed a comedy routine nobody got
screwed up from a comedy routine to work
around at all is you know and he was so
smart but so impractical I mean he would
go out and do the yard work to save you
know 50 cents an hour and in those
meetings so anyway I'm trying to find
every week I try and find all the
peculiarities I go back to the writers
and say would you change this or change
that well I got 11 and the cats that are
just delicious probably hated burger in
the show was celebrating his 50th
wedding anniversary right and you've
been married to Barbara Streisand for 20
years is that right yeah we've been
together 23 years how's it going yeah
good partnership well figuring out the
divorce really probably is 70% your your
problem go fix yourself and stick around
because it's expensive too the real
answer is Connie sellecca actually
showed me something she went and got
married after she said I quit that's it
and when she'd finally met somebody John
Tesh they went to a shrink for six
months in advance because there's always
one of the two that don't want to sit
down and negotiate the problem so this
is pre before they had where they got
married and so they've had a long
wonderful marriage and from that
actually my wife showed me that if we
ever have a problem bring in somebody
who's nice for us both to sit with talk
it out and poof one hour later it's gone
whatever was bothering you for weeks
probably was your own and she Barbara is
okay with with marital counseling
because she's so firm and
it was her that brought it that brought
it that's good yeah you're okay with it
too obviously oh no I loved it actually
I think that really enjoyed your process
too
to be honest can I ask you about
building an airplane which you've also
done this year yeah what is that what's
that like well you know there's a lot of
kit planes under the experimental rules
now you know and I know that scares a
lot of people but they still under the
FAA are um what we've got a picture of
it yeah oh no no that it's not that that
was I invested in a jet charter you're
really talented I would fly the
right-hand seat in Morelos but no I'm uh
I'm uh you know a bush pilot a backyard
pilot 21 years in primetime huh or 22
years in some time yeah keep going james
brolin love you mean i think you got
some games yeah got something here
we might get picked up here huh we don't
know we do we got four weeks that well
there's a good for people to see you
here and then to see the show it's good
I've watched the first two episodes
already uh you I James bow and we thank
you season four of life and pieces
premieres tonight with two new episodes
8:30 and 9:30 or 7:30 and 8:30 central
time right here on on CBS CBS eight
thirty nine thirty